[موسيقى]
غامضه ومبهره وغير عاديه قصور وقلاع تشتمل
على اعلى مستويات الدقه والجمل ولدت من
رحم الخيال لا محدود للمبدعها مثل ما هو
الحال في مدينه ادريس باقليم لادغام جنوب
شرق فرنسا حيث توجد قلعه
كل سنه يحاول 190 الف زائرين الغوص في
غمار اسرارها الغامضه
هناك مزيج من العديد من العناصر
الانتقائيه المتناغمه مع بعضها البعض بشكل
رائع
لم يكن مهندسا ولا نحاته كان سعيه بريد
متواضع من القرن التاسع عشر بعد جولاته
اليوميه يعود كل مساء محملا بكتل من
الاحجار ليشيد لبنه لبنه قصره المثالي
استغرق ثلاثه 33 عاما لدينا هنا اعمده
ضخمه براس كائن القنط تحملها اربعه اعمده
صغيره مرممون هذه القلعه يقولون دائما
انهم لا يعرفون كيف يتماسك كل هذا فهو
يتحدى قانون الجاذبيه لغز معماري تهدسه
مجسمات الحيوانات والشخصيات الخرافيه
المستوحاه من الاساطير اليونانيه والشرقيه
انتشرت صور حينها في جميع الصحف والمجلات
والبطاقه البريديه التي كان يوزعها شيفال
بنفسه
ندخل الان الى احدى القاعات
التي الابداعا اعجوبه حقيقيه من المنحوتات
الاستثنائيه
وهنا اصداف انشاها بشكل مقلوب ليترك بصمته
الخاصه على هذا العمل
عمل فني اثار في بداياته السخريه لدى
البعض كان ذلك في حياه صاحبه طبعا قبل ان
يجد له صدا كبيرا بين السريانيين والعديد
من الفنانين امثال بيكاسو يصير القصر فيما
بعد رمزا للفن الطبيعي ليس ذلك فحسب بل لا
زال حتى اليوم ملهما لكثير الفنانين
ايضا طريقه جيده لفهمه وادراك جميع خباياه
نضيع فيه ولا نفهم كل شيء منه لكنه ينقلنا
اليه تماما انه لغز وعمل شاعري بامتياز
اراد من خلاله ساعي البريد البسيط شيفال
ترك بصمته عبر التاريخ قصر مليء بالالغاز
والاسرار يصنف اليوم ضمن المعادن
التاريخيه في فرنسا تحفه اخرى لابد من
رؤيتها ولغز حجري من نوع خاص وسط حقول
مدينه مايان بالغرب الفرنسي تؤثثه شخصيات
سكرت مخيله الفنان روبرتا خلال طفولته
انها مدخنه نتخيل الدخان يتصاعد منه نحن
امام العنصر الاول النار
انه رائع لم اكن اتوقع على الاطلاق ان ارى
اشياء كثيره به راء هائل في هذا المكان
الصغير هل لديك القدره على تخيل طريقه
بنائه ليس كثيرا لابد من البحث لانه يحتوي
على العديد من الاشياء والعلامات الغامضه
انه معقد جدا
لمحاوله فهم توجه روبر الفني علينا ان
نلقي نظره على مشواره وحياته الشخصيه كان
طالبا في الفنون الجميله في باريس وكان
ايضا دهانا ونجارا ثم صانع خزف يروض اداه
النقش بالسهوله نفسها التي يتعامل بها مع
فرشاه الرسم والفلسفه
تبدو لك عوالم خاصه في جبين هذه الشخصيه
وعوالم اخرى هنا وهنا لكنها تظل عوالم
واحده في كل هذا الرسم منزله الذي يوجد
داخل القلعه التي صارت متحفا ظل على حاله
منذ وفاته عام
1983 جميع تفاصيله ابدعها الفنان على
طريقته الخاصه لم يكن هناك اي فرق بين
حياته كفنان وحياته اليوميه كان يلقب
غالبا بالعامل الفنانه لانه
لوظيفته كعامل ووظيفته كفنان وتمكن من
الاستفاده من الاثنين
لكن هل يمكن ان نجد خطا هنا او هناك في
هذه الابداعات التي خلدها اولئك الفنانون
من المحتمل ذلك كما يقول البعض لكن
بالتاكيد ليس مع قصر بيوت هذه التحفه
المعماريه المتراميه على بحر الكود جنوب
فرنسا والمصممه ضمن اشكال دائريه كل شيء
دائري ويتحرك
هذا الابداع الدائري يعود للفنان
مهندس معماري فنلندي ينتمي الى المدرسه
الطبيعيه استقر في الريفيرا الفرنسيه في
سنوات السبعينيات رسم مخططات هذا القصر ثم
باع المنزل
مصمم الازياء الشهيه اتخذ من هذا المكان
مصدر الهام
لقد صمم مثل جسم الانسان الممرات فيه
بمثابه الشرايين والاوعيه والعروق لديه
ايضا راس ودماغ لم يعد اليوم يسكن اي احد
في قصر بيل جون باسكال مساعد سابق هو من
يتكفل حاليا بالحفاظ على هذا المبنى
المترامي على مساحه 2000 متر مربع
[موسيقى]
تصميم هذا القصر مثل تصميم منزلي بيل
هندسته شبيهه بجسم الانسان مع اطلاله على
هذا المسبح الذي يعد الاول من نوعه من حيث
اطلالته الرائعه على مياه القداس يوجد به
12 جناحا مؤثث بما يتماشى مع هذا التصميم
الدائري لدينا في جميع الاجنحه سرير دائري
مع مراحيض دائريه وحمام وحوض استحمام
دائري كل شيء مستدير
قصر بي لوضع للبيع منذ وفاه
قدر ثمنه باربعمائه مليون يورو ما يجعله
واحدا من اكثر المنازل الباهظه الثمن في
العالم لكنه سيظل قبل كل شيء قصرف فنان لا
يقدر باي ثمن